reculer pour mieux sauter voilà comment
on pourrait résumer la position de
l'union européenne vis-à-vis de certains
insecticides considérés comme des tueurs
d'abeilles ces présumés assassins porte
un nom les néonicotinoïdes et on tue
deux méthodes s'attaquer au système
nerveux central des insectes leurs
effets sont dévastateurs y compris sur
certaines espèces non visés notamment
les abeilles chez qui ils engendrent
différents troubles du système
reproducteur du sens de l'orientation ou
encore du mouvement de leur zèle ce
faisant il contribue au déclin massif
des colonies de pollinisateurs dont
dépend la reproduction de nombreuses
espèces végétales un danger dont l'union
européenne a pris conscience est
interdit d' usage en plein champ depuis
2018 c'est une décision très importante
prise par l'europe on ne s'y attendait
pas mais j'en suis très heureux
l'union européenne montre qu'elle est
capable de répondre présente quand il
s'agit de biodiversité et de la santé de
ses citoyens trois ans plus tard le ton
a changé car onze états membres ont
adopté depuis des autorisations
d'urgence pour permettre aux
agriculteurs de recourir à nouveau aux
produits contenant ces substances
parmi eux la france a accordé en août
2020 une dérogation temporaire aux
planteurs de betteraves confronté à une
prolifération de pucerons verts porteur
de la jaunisse virale cette
réintroduction temporaire a une nouvelle
fois été autorisée en février dernier
pour une période de 120 jours
conséquence l'année 2021 est une
catastrophe pour le miel français le
climat évidemment n'a pas aidé mais les
insecticides ont eu un impact non
négligeable quand on voit que des
députés ont voté pour la réintroduction
des néonicotinoïdes pour favoriser la
culture de la betterave sucrière nocifs
pour les abeilles dans la culture mais
déclare label grande cause pour 2022
année électorale c'est fallacieux les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en
occitanie deuxième ou troisième région
productrice en france selon les années
entre 7000 et 9000 tonnes de miel sont
attendus en 2021 contre 15000 les années
précédentes une perte de 50%
pratiquement en outre bien que
parfaitement conscientes de leur
nocivité la france comme d'autres pays
européens continuent de produire
massivement ces insecticides et même de
les exporter une enquête publiée par
neuf la cellule investigation de la
branche britannique de greenpeace des
voies orales que les autorités
européennes ont donné leur feu vert aux
demandes d'exportation d'environ 4000
tonnes de pesticides contenant plus de
700 tonnes de ces substances actives
on estime à environ 300 le nombre
d'exportations approuvé entre le 1er
septembre et le 31 décembre 2020 à
destination de 65 pays différents neuf
pays européens sont concernés par ce
commerce qualifiée de toxique par les
ong en première position on retrouve la
belgique avec 310 tonnes exportées la
france arrive deuxième avec 157 tonnes
l'allemagne complètent le podium avec 97
tonnes les principaux responsables de
cette aberration les géants de
l'agrochimie depuis des décennies les
fabricants font tout pour minimiser le
rôle des néonicotinoïdes dans
l'effondrement des abeilles en
instrumentalisant la science et à grand
renfort de greenwashing
les états doivent agir pour sauver la
biodiversité en interdisant
l'exportation de substances prohibées
sur leur propre territoire
malgré sa l'union européenne continue de
fermer les yeux même si une proposition
de loi est en préparation en france ce
commerce elle ne devrait plus être
possible dans quelques mois la loi sur
l'alimentation promulguée en 2018
prévoir à l'interdiction à partir de
2022 de la production du stockage et de
la circulation de ces produits contenant
des substances actives non autorisée en
europe une décision forte en dépit des
pressions exercées par les fabricants de
pesticides notamment de multiples
recours devant les tribunaux pendant ce
temps bruxelles joue la montre il est
prématuré de déterminer quel produit
chimique pourrait faire l'objet d'une
mesure éventuel puisque nous sommes
encore en train d'évaluer quelles sont
les mesures les plus appropriées
l'urgence est pourtant bel et bien réel
depuis l'introduction de néonicotinoïdes
les populations de police acteurs se
sont effondrés à l'échelle de la planète
faisant peser une sérieuse menace sur la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale selon
l'onu un tiers de la production agricole
mondiale dépend des abeilles et des
pollinisateurs